okay let's take another look at the
Monty Hall tree that we worked with to
figure out the probability of the switch
strategy winning now this tree was just
absolutely literal and and absurdly
complicated and large for what we're
trying to analyze that is we literally
thought of each of the three outcomes of
whether the prize was behind door one
door two door three and then which
exactly which door the contestant picked
next either door one door two door three
and so on and it's clear that this tree
has a symmetric structure that is these
three sub trees whether the prize is
behind one the prize is behind two where
the prize is behind three all have the
same structure and we could have gotten
away with analyzing one and deduce that
that's what happened with the other two
branches in fact that really was what we
did but why not make that explicit in
our analysis from the first place
instead of it having this triple tree
let's just look at the tree with one
branch so there's the central branch
that I'm keeping namely we're assuming
that the first move is to have the prize
at door - and then the door picked has
three choices and then the door opened
has two choices or one depending on
where the prize was placed relative to
the contestant spec here if the prize
was a two and the contestant picked door
- then Carol has a choice of two doors
one or three to open on the other hand
if the prize was a - and the contestant
picked door one Carol has no choice but
to open door three with probability one
okay now when we're looking at this tree
the first branch is kind of fixed and
forced so we don't really need it as
part of the analysis what we're really
looking at is the analyzing what happens
in the experiment starting at the stage
where the contestant picks a door so
let's just enlarge this tree to get a
better look at it there's the same tree
where we're starting off where we're
assuming that the prize is a door - and
then the door pick can be either door
one door toward or three and the door
open then can be door three door one
door three or door one
according to the constraints on Carol
now a way to a better way to understand
this tree as instead of saying the
prizes at door - and this is where the
contestant chooses door - and then have
to worry about all the other branches
that are symmetrically like this we
could have reformulated the tree model
in the first place by saying let's just
consider the cases that wherever the
prize is there are three possibilities
the contestant picks the door where the
prize is or they pick the next door with
a let's say in some counterclockwise
direction from where the prize is or
going around among the doors in a circle
they pick a door that they pick a door
that's two doors away from where the
prize is and if we reformulate it that
way then we're these are the cases
either the contestant picks the prize
door or they pick the first door that
doesn't have the prize or they pick the
second door that doesn't have the prize
in each of those occur with probability
1/3 and likewise once they've picked
door number one with no prize then that
means that carol has the choice of only
one door that she can open because the
other unpick door has a prize so she's
got to open the nope the second no prize
door because the contestant has picked
the first no prize door likewise if the
contestant picks the prize door Carol
can pick either the non prize either of
the nine prize doors non prize one or
non prize - both our losses and likewise
here where Carol's move is forced and
the contestant will win now we're in
great shape because I've really gotten
rid of the rest of the tree it's not as
though I'm analyzing 1/3 of it and the
1/3 analysis is going to apply to the
other parts by symmetry but I've
captured the whole story here by simply
relativizing the first move instead of
it being literally door one door two
door three I don't care what the actual
door the contestant picks all I care
about is whether the contestant picks
the prize door or the first door that's
not the prize door or the
second tour that's not the prize door
this would have been a much better tree
to start off with in the first place
at least for the purpose of analyzing
the probability of winning now we're
gonna get some mileage out of the more
complicated tree and then in a later
video segment when we start talking
about conditional probabilities of what
are the probabilities of things
happening at various stages in the
experiment and so we will want to have
some of these other vertices that
represent stages of the experiment but
if we'd really been thinking solely
about how to analyze the probability of
winning with the stretch strategy this
would have been a much better tree to
start off with but wait let's look at
this tree first of all there really
isn't any need to model this branch of
the experiment because at this point
once the we're talking about switching
if the contestant has picked the non
prize door they win period Carroll's
move is forced and it's going to be a
win we might have well well just
collapsed the win dontoh say that as
soon as they pick a non-price door
they've won and who cares what happens
after that same thing down here so the
tree really could have simplified to one
where you pick a no prize door and you
wind you pick a note the other no prize
door and you win or you pick a prize
door and then carol has a choice of
opening either of the other two nope
you
okay because after all um what's the
point in distinguishing between whether
you pick prized or won or you pick
prized or - you win in both cases and
really all we care about we could have
convinced the entire tree down to one
where either you pick the prized or with
probability 1/3 in which case you're
guaranteed to lose no matter what
happens or you pick the non prized or
which you do with probability 2/3 in
which case you win no matter what
happens and that is a really simple tree
ok there it is and what we can read off
immediately is that with the switch
strategy the probability of winning is
2/3 so the switch wins if and only if
the prize door is not picked and that
means that the probability that switch
wins is 2/3 which is what we already
figured out using the more complicated
tree but this way of getting at it is a
lot clearer so the message here is that
the the tree that you come up with to
model the experimental outcomes is
really a modeling process and there may
be many models that work to capture a
given scenario and it will often pay off
to try to find a simpler tree to make
the analysis simpler